how's the gum risk mighty fine so why -
welcome to talk a hair salon I used to
play this game with my girlfriend but
they came out with a new one
I'm gonna show you how it works it's for
kids but it's actually pretty funny okay
it's funny I know it's not hard game
goddamnit all right here we go let me
take a picture oh hello nice you see
that PewDiePie face up close all right
let's do it perfect okay okay there we
go I don't think I'm supposed to smile
like that there we go oh man I look so
good let's try to make my hair the way I
have it right now or so [ __ ] like that
oh god it's so creepy Oh easy
shut up pets god you're annoying do you
ever be quiet do you ever be quiet dead
English why do I sound like a
transvestite
what's my hair color I like it why do I
become possessed every time I do
something look at my tongue oh you like
that don't you it's my t-shirt wet - oh
I look like a final fantasy character
nice I always wanted to have a black
afro well that's pretty attractive let's
be honest a nice little unibrow - that's
nice holy [ __ ] that Marge Simpson sure
you could really get it I think I should
get a knife right all right I guess I'll
just square this cat hat yeah you like
that [ __ ] don't you little pits no come
on what about a hair bag
well you look so good oh my god all
right and there we go we have myself
let's take a picture
nice if I close my eyes okay it's just
so what else oh I know I know I wonder
if this will work oh god this is gonna
be creepy go all right let's the other
step
we're gonna Steve what happened why are
you a ginger pretty sure you're not a
ginger nice oh that's better
ah much better I like this you should
keep this one Edgar man and getter you
look fabulous
let's make him cross through the crown
all right how about this we try to make
him as human as possible oh let's give
him the Anthony Padilla's old haircut oh
my god my dog is Anthony weird man hey
okay we need to cover up that he doesn't
have a nose wonderful no hat why do I
always have to make it so uncomfortable
for myself
no one resists hello have my dog is a
little cross-eyed - it looks even better
than oh [ __ ] you okay there we go that's
the picture oh it's so incredibly ugly
hey there's a line I can do oh god stop
talking okay this should be good yeah
it's probably gonna be bad make it fit
well this part is easy oh god I came to
pick them up come on this is gonna look
terrible how are you crying oh it's
[ __ ] awkward man let's see if I can
fix a better picture I can just
Photoshop something that's the cry I
know don't worry guys it's gonna be okay
don't be scared Jojo please can't cry
it's gonna be okay just calm it over hey
you guys trust me cry you're gonna look
fabulous
all right let's shave it
you go this looks pretty identical I cry
but there's one thing missing beautiful
let's give him a nose and a moustache
all right cries done Oh God
okay let's do Ken next all right I was a
beard gonna work this is never gonna
work
he's kind of doing the duck face Oh God
ken no go away man what is this what is
how am I gonna work with me silver has
always been your a collar Ken I think
you should wait sorry first we have to
shampoo you my where's my matter you're
a son so I came looking really fabulous
look I just can't he's so Ike
nothing Sookie oh there you go
I don't know what to do for you can
seriously it's giving some banks only
that's all he gets you likes it he looks
pretty good in bags
there you see press obviously yo your
hair is still wet
come on I gotta do everything here Oh
God now your hair is all improving
Kenny's gonna kill me he likes it
let's be honest miss Toller thing there
from tidies double chin I think that's
pretty good Ken done next one is of
course is that supposed to be attractive
like it looks like he really has to take
a [ __ ] but is holding it in that's the
face I do when I have to so Justin will
be the girl doing some kind of weird
duck face I don't know which one did it
I Oh God kill it kill it
ah here's something to be wanting to do
for a long time
oh you dirty [ __ ] don't tell me you
don't like it it's gonna be okay let's
jump Oh your hair yeah that's right
however I forgot of course try it and
then we're gonna color it yeah try take
it take it
okay I want I want em to have a little
hair oh I like this this is some kinky
[ __ ] I can work with kinky [ __ ] that
looks pretty nice if we you ask me there
we go and then we just pull it down
there we go that's pretty nice and then
we'll finish off with our god is
disgusting Justin Bieber ladies and
gentlemen now I teach you not to sing
again pose oh god they go out he likes
it
Justin Bieber approves how she just
opened my own hair salon holy [ __ ]
I am a natural talent obviously I pursue
he would take it baby pits this is me
when I was a baby I like that little
drool that I have they're very
attractive very attractive Oh God so
weird to see you like uh get away why do
is ginger I don't I don't even know this
guy there's a lot of fun
hope you brother's enjoyed watching yeah
living this a little bit different but I
didn't have that much time today anyway
I hope you've was enjoying watching
nevertheless they like if you did I
really appreciate it hit subscribe
Okumura today and I see you Bruce in the
next 1000 breasts
love you
[Music]
these times are too tight man
oh the break and stuff
[Music]
now that